[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous c'est
une édition spéciale de sciences
publiques que l'on vous propose avec la
rédaction de Public Sénat deux heures
après la location du président de la
République depuis l'Élysée un peu plus
de 13 minutes pour lancer 3 grands
chantiers et donner un rendez-vous pour
un bilan de ses chantiers dans 100 jours
les trois chantiers le travail la
justice et l'ordre républicain et puis
la refondation de nos services publics
notamment l'éducation nationale et le
système de santé on va en débattre
évidemment dans un premier temps avec
mes invités politiques et puis ensuite
dans un second temps avec nos experts
politologues sondeurs et spécialistes en
communication mais d'abord je vous
propose de réécouter le début de la
location d'Emmanuel Macron quand il
explique il parle évidemment en
ouverture de la réforme de retraite
pourquoi c'est très formalité nécessaire
selon lui et puis ensuite il reconnaît
qu'elle n'est toujours pas acceptée
adopter conformément à ce que prévoit
notre Constitution ces changements
étaient nécessaires pour garantir la
retraite de chacun et pour produire plus
de richesses pour notre nation
car en effet alors que le nombre de
retraités augmente que notre espérance
de vie s'allonge la réponse ne pouvait
pas être de baisser les pensions elle ne
pouvait pas être non plus d'augmenter
les cotisations de ceux qui travaillent
et ne pouvait pas être comme je l'ai
beaucoup entendu de ne rien faire car
c'était alors laisser les déficits
s'accumuler et notre dette augmentée
pour les générations futures
ces changements étaient donc nécessaires
et constitue un effort c'est vrai mais
il est accompagné de mesures de justice
d'amélioration concrète pour ceux qui
ont eu des carrières longues exercées
des métiers les plus durs ou qui
perçoivent les petites retraites
travailler tous progressivement un peu
plus comme l’ont d'ailleurs fait tous
nos voisins européens c'est aussi
produire plus de richesses pour notre
pays tout entier et c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être plus fort d'investir pour
notre quotidien et pour notre avenir et
nous en avons besoin
pour autant
cette réforme est-elle acceptée à
l'évidence non et malgré les mois de
concertation un consensus n'a pas pu
être trouvé et je le regrette
nous devons en tirer tous les
enseignements
j'ai entendu dans les manifestations une
opposition à sa réforme des retraites
mais aussi une volonté de retrouver du
sens dans son travail dans améliorer les
conditions d'avoir des carrières qui
permettent de progresser dans la vie
plus généralement c'est une colère qui
s'est exprimée
colère face à un travail qui pour trop
de Français ne permet plus de bien vivre
face à des prix qui montent qu'il
s'agisse du plein des courses de la
cantine car malgré une mobilisation de
l'État inédite en Europe l'augmentation
des prix pèse sur nos vies quotidiennes
cette colère c'est aussi une colère
parce que certains ont le sentiment de
faire leur part
mais sans être récompensé de leurs
efforts ni en aide ni en service public
efficace
c'est toute cette colère que de très
nombreux Français ont exprimé en
manifestants et pour l'immense majorité
dans le calme et le respect de nos
institutions
personne et surtout pas moi ne peut
rester sourd à cette revendication de
justice sociale et de rénovation de
notre vie démocratique en particulier
exprimée par notre jeunesse
et pour notre premier débat j'accueille
Xavier bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur des pays des
Hauts-de-Seine soutiennent évidemment du
président de la République Stéphane
dublier bonsoir c'est l'air des
Bouches-du-Rhône Sophie et Polly en
bonsoir vous êtes dépité Europe Écologie
Les Verts donc au sein de la nuque
députée génération mais vice-présidente
du groupe écologiste très bien et vous
êtes donc également au sein de la Nupe
et députés du Val-de-Marne et Émilie
appelle ski bonsoir Émilie spécialiste
en communication politique électoriste
pour ce sens public je reprends Xavier
les propos du président 100 jours
jusqu'au 14 juillet il a donné son
rendez-vous pour agir au service de la
France ça veut dire qu'il a choisi
d'accélérer plutôt que d'apaiser non il
a eu d'ailleurs utilisé le mot
apaisement 100 jours pour apaiser son
jour aussi d'action parce que ni
immobilisme ni extremisme c'est ce sont
ces mots une volonté aussi d'associer
beaucoup plus les mers les élus les
syndicats dans ce qu'il a de ses vœux
d'une nouvelle coalition dès le mois de
mai en tout cas un travail d'une
nouvelle coalition une coalition de de
projet pour pour les Français au service
des Français et donc c'est tout tout ce
travail de concertation qui va falloir
mener et qu'il souhaite mener avec une
feuille de route qui est donnée à la
première ministre qui sera qui sera
présenté dès la semaine prochaine
qu'est-ce qu'il vous fera Sophie et
polluant dans le discours du président
République marine tondeuillier la
secrétaire général d'Europe Écologie
verte parle de l'absence de remise en
question il y a plusieurs choses qui me
frappent d'abord c'est un début qui est
quand même un début de discours qui
revient sur sur un certain nombre de
mensonges qui ont été proférés par le
gouvernement le fait de dire qu'il y a
des avancées dans le texte des retraites
alors qu'elles ont été supprimées par le
Conseil constitutionnel le fait non mais
enfin je veux dire il y a une
présentation des choses qui est
totalement biaisée donc ça moi je trouve
ça hallucinant on est on est quand même
censé là enfin il voulait tourner la
page etc Il leur met une louche enfin
quelque part en tenant ses propos
complètement à côté de la plaque parce
que il nous réexplique ce qui nous a
expliqué avant mais les gens ils ont
bien compris ils ont pas besoin qu'on
leur explique d'un air gentil ils ont
compris qu'ils ne veulent pas de cette
réforme parce que ça pose la question
nous interrompre un nouveau pack de la
vie au travail il intègre ces
éléments-là effectivement qui ont été
retoqués par le Conseil constitutionnel
dans une future négociation après il
fait comme si il était au début d'un
quinquennat
c'est amusant cette cette référence au
100 jours qui dans notre démocratie
font appel à l'imaginaire de la quand on
arrive au pouvoir et qu'on a cette
énergie réformatrice mais il n'est pas
au début de son quinquennat ça fait un
mois ça fait un an qu'il est déjà là et
finalement c'est un quinquina
complètement encalminé il est très seul
ce président de la République très seul
il essaye de se convaincre qui va
avancer mais on se demande avec qui il
parle de dialogue social avec les
organisations syndicales mais quand ils
commencent à dérouler ce qui va proposer
sur le travail on entend quoi on entend
ce qu'il dit déjà depuis des mois et des
années c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a aucune
évolution vous voyez donc en fait on est
dans un décalage entre on va commencer
alors qu'en fait c'est dans la poursuite
on va faire avec des gens mais il est
isolé et on va faire du nouveau alors
qu'il nous sert exactement les mêmes
mots qu'il disait auparavant alors vous
aurez l'occasion de répondre évidemment
dans un instant sur l'absence de
nouveautés Stéphane Lorie dulier cette
coalition elle est jusqu'à présent
refusée d'en faire partie ça pourrait
changer
déjà coalition ça veut dire quoi
concrètement parce qu'on met dedans
pardon qu'est-ce qu'on met dedans
qu'est-ce qu'on met dedans pour
l'instant ce sont des mots on verra si
il y aura un changement méthode parce
que ce qu'il manque dans cette
allocution c'est quelle nouvelle méthode
j'apporte pour clairement porter les
réformes qui sont assez ambitieuses les
trois trois grandes trois grandes
dossiers les trois grands chantiers sont
très ambitieux on parle de réforme de la
justice réforme du travail mais cela dit
on est toujours dans une majorité pour
leur relative et la deuxième question
qui se pose c'est est-ce qu'on peut
porter ces trois grands chantiers avec
le même gouvernement avec la même
première ministre qui a quand même été
assez abîmé dans dans le cadre de cette
séquence des retraites donc c'est toutes
ces questions là en suspens qui me
laisse un peu perplexe même si le cap
clairement il y a une barre à droite
quoi qu'on en dise je ne pas cracher sur
la réforme de la justice ou sur la
réforme de l'école la justice c'est pas
de droite ni de gauche sans la justice
on sent vraiment qu'à la barre est à
droite puisqu'il a compris clairement
qu'il fallait au minimum 40 députés LR
pour un soir une majorité alors absolue
vous voyez pas forcément le coup de bar
à droite donc vous allez pouvoir
répondre là dessus et puis en même temps
au fait qu'il y a rien de vraiment
nouveau dans cette dans cette allocution
présidentielle selon Sophie taipoli moi
je vois pas de bar à droite ou bar à
gauche et pas la question est pas là la
question est que le cap est fixée par le
Président de la République il donne une
feuille de route au gouvernement et à la
première ministre il dit qu'on fera une
première un premier point d'étape au
mois de juillet le 14 juillet
effectivement
pour des chantiers aussi importants à la
fois c'est une c'est une première étape
c'est à dire que dit un certain nombre
de chantier ont déjà été lancés
notamment sur la question de la justice
sur la question de l'ordre
républicain aussi je parle je pense
notamment à la Loi sur le ministère de
l'intérieur de la loterie qui nous
permet effectivement de lancer ses 200
brigades dans la ruralité de gendarmerie
pour avoir effectivement plus de bleu
sur le terrain qui était une des
promesses du Président de la République
lors de la campagne Jean magistrat ou
d'agents par le garde des sceaux depuis
que ça donne raison il y a un nouveau
mais il y a un nouveau mais il y a en
fait la réalité c'est qu'il faut que
maintenant que ça aboutisse parce que ce
sont des annonces de campagne un certain
nombre de projets ont été lancés je
pense notamment effectivement il a
raison aussi de rappeler quand il dit un
nouveau pacte de la vie au travail en
rappelant effectivement que depuis six
ans c'est 1,7 millions d'emplois qui ont
été créés de par les mesures aussi
d'accompagnement des entreprises et de
soutien aux économie de notre entreprise
de nouvelles entreprises pardon qui ont
été créés et ce nouveau pacte de la vie
au travail avec ce dialogue social sans
tabou il l'a dit sans tabou cette
ouverture aussi sans tabou sur toutes
les mesures à la fois qui ont été
censurées par le Conseil constitutionnel
mais aussi toutes les mesures que les
partenaires sociaux voudront mettre sur
la table sur la pénibilité sur l'usure
au travail sur aussi les travail des
seniors et tout ce qui touche en fait à
la vie de l'entreprise et des
travailleurs on peut quand même dire que
la porte est ouverte tardivement mais la
portée est ouverte aujourd'hui Sophie
est ouverte pas d'autre choix il est
tout seul dans la pièce donc il essaie
et de chercher et chercher des
partenaires alors oui oui la porte est
ouverte
autour de la table
pour faire visiblement une réforme du
travail qui est celle finalement dont il
parle déjà depuis plusieurs semaines
comme je le disais mais s'il voulait
faire une réforme du travail en lien
vraiment avec ce que demande les
organisations syndicales il lui faudrait
d'abord revenir sur les ordonnances
travail et Laurent Berger l'a dit tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui si on a des
questions notamment de prise en compte
sur la pénibilité c'est aussi parce que
Monsieur Macron a supprimé 4 des
critères de pénibilité qui étaient pris
en compte dans le premier la première
version du compte pénibilité si
aujourd'hui on a des problèmes de
prévention des risques au travail c'est
parce que les CHSCT ont été supprimés si
aujourd'hui on a des problèmes au
travail sur les risques professionnels
c'est parce qu'on a diminué encore et
encore le nombre d'inspecteurs du
travail si aujourd'hui on a des
problèmes dans le monde du travail c'est
notamment des travailleurs pauvres c'est
aussi parce que avec ces ordonnances et
toutes sa philosophie derrière la
politique de Monsieur Macron on a
précarisé à outrance vous savez que
avant on pouvait pas embaucher un
intérimaire juste pour une heure si on
l'embauchait pour une heure on le payait
la journée c'est une protection des
travailleurs mais maintenant une heure
une heure comment voulez-vous avoir
aujourd'hui une situation dans le monde
du travail d'apaisement quand on est
dans un tel ou tel pressurisation des
travailleurs et des travailleurs
et puis finalement je peux en tenir bien
plus longtemps est-ce qu'il va falloir
reconstruire ce qui a été déconstruit
par par le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron en quelque sorte sur
la question du travail sur la question
du travail il l'a dit qu'il voulait
reprendre les discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux sans tabou donc sans
tabou à partir du moment où il y a pas
de tabou moi je prends au pied de la
lettre c'est à dire que les partenaires
sociaux arrivent avec des propositions
avec des négociations et avec des
demandes qui pourraient être de revoir
un certain moment moi je ne suis pas sûr
je ne suis pas oui mais là on en était
pas les ordonnances c'était pas lié aux
retraites en l'occurrence et donc moi je
pense qu'il faut reprendre le dialogue
avec syndicales et patronales et faire
en sorte de trouver ce nouveau de pacte
du travail de la vie au travail qui est
des millions
parce que c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois qu'on entend autant un
appel à la fois au syndicat ou forces
politiques on a entendu je vais mieux
les associer donc c'est en creux une
reconnaissance un petit peu que il
n'associe pas assez tous les corps
intermédiaires ce qui lui reproché
depuis longtemps et en même temps il y a
ces 100 jours c'est assez contradictoire
parce que d'un côté on dit je vous ouvre
la porte en plus on sait que les
syndicats pour le moment on dit avant le
1er mai no way ce n'est pas possible et
il y a cette exigence d'aller vite un
petit peu comme cette méthode qu'on a eu
auparavant qui allait au pas de course
et qui laissait pas tellement le temps à
la concertation à la discussion pour
créer un peu un apaisement et un partage
des idées apaisement et accélération je
vais vous donner la parole là-dessus
dans un court instant je propose de
réécouter un extrait de la locution
d'Emmanuel Macron justement cette porte
ouverte au syndicat
et proposer de recevoir les
organisations patronales et syndicales
dès demain matin pour celles qui sont
prêtes et la porte sera toujours ouverte
et cela afin d'ouvrir sans aucune limite
sans aucun tabou une série de
négociations sur des sujets essentiels
améliorer les revenus des salariés
faire progresser les carrières mieux
partager la richesse améliorer les
conditions de travail trouver des
solutions à l'usure professionnelle
accroître l'emploi des seniors et aider
au reconversion
ce nouveau pacte de la vie au travail
sera construit dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent par le dialogue social
[Musique]
qu'on arrive à apaiser la population
donc je pense que là il y va un peu la
cavalcade et c'est ça risque d'être un
effet boomerang au mois de juillet quand
on s'apercevra qu'effectivement ce qu'il
a annoncé comme veut ne s'est pas
réellement mais c'est pour ça que je
démarrais avec cette question de ces
deux verbes apaiser accélérer même si
effectivement il a employé le terme de
d'apaiser l'apaisement ce qu'on retient
c'est les 100 jours
Xavier donc donc ce sentiment quand même
mais peut-être à Justine moi je prends
pas parti là-dessus mais qui met la
pression au partenaires sociaux qui
jusqu'à présent veulent pas lui parler
mais un point d'étape au bout de 100
jours c'est pas la ligne d'arrivée c'est
une étape c'est un ravitaillement il va
vouloir des résultats il va vouloir on
connaît Emmanuel Macron il va vouloir
des résultats attendez est-ce que c'est
pas la France d'ailleurs que le
Président de la République qui fixe un
cap qui a été élu par les français pour
ça ne demande pas un point d'étape au
bout de 100 jours en ayant fixé un cap
avec le gouvernement et les partenaires
sociaux c'est tout à fait normal de
demander un point d’étape après moi ce
que je voudrais juste te répondre sur ce
que mon collègue a fait comme
intervention sur la méthode sur la
question des retraites moi je peux
l'entendre je peux entendre
effectivement mais je me rappelle aussi
que vous êtes dans la majorité
sénatoriale majorité scénario qui depuis
des années veut l'allongement de la
durée de légal de notre mort à 64 ans ou
65 ans par amendement au pffss je parle
chaque année oui je veux bien un
amendement d'appeler
toujours voter non mais attendez moi
c'est un collègue c'est un abonnement
qui est toujours voté par la majorité
sénatoriale et vous l'assumez et moi
j'ai pas de problème avec ça mais ne
nous reprochez pas quelque chose que
vous faites chaque année lors du vote du
budget vous confondez un projet de loi
qui aurait dû être complet c'est une
réforme du monde du travail et également
de s'interroger sur comment travailler
davantage tout au long de la vie il y
avait peut-être aussi d'autres solutions
à avoir je sais que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord sur la capitalisation mais à un
moment donné il faudra peut-être changer
de paradigme également mais ce sujet là
c'est des balades n'ont pas pu la voir
nous n'avons pas été au fond des sujets
vous savez très bien puisque c'était un
temps vous dire que sur les temps
programmés c'était un temps programmé
au Sénat nous avons eu le débat y
compris sur la question
c'est ce que j'ai dit vendredi matin sur
ce plateau par rapport au cavaliers
sociaux allez détricoter le texte sur
des débats de fonds comme l'a annoncé le
président
il a mis la charrue avant les bœufs
Sophie tailler le Conseil
constitutionnel a validé cette procédure
il a retoqué un certain nombre de
cavaliers sociaux mais il a validé la
procédure et notamment la rapidité de la
procédure ça il faut le redire quand
même par rapport à la discussion
précédente c'est que ce que demandait
les organisations syndicales c'est de
commencer par les questions liées au
travail voyez donc là maintenant vient
leur dire bah c'est maintenant venez
apaisement etc alors qu'en fait c'est ce
qui demandait dès le départ que le
comprennent les choses dans le bon ordre
et là on vient leur expliquer qu'ils ont
eu tort qu'ils ont perdu mais qu'il
faudrait même qu'il me vient qui
reviennent alors que bien sûr c'était la
bonne façon de de travailler
cette occasion après sur la question de
la réforme est de la vie du Conseil
constitutionnels donc je vous redemande
est-ce qu'il faut pas quand même saisir
cette
occasion cette cette porte ouverte là
pour de vraies grandes négociations sur
le travail la valeur travail la
rémunération le sens du travail alors
d'accord ça va peut-être été fait à
l'envers mais là il y a une opportunité
non seulement ça a été fait à l'envers
mais visiblement ça continue à être fait
sur des bases qui ne sont pas celles que
demandent les organisations syndicales
quand j'entends par exemple quand
j'entends partage de la valeur ce qui a
été dit ce qui traîne dans les 1 voilà
ça veut dire que on va être sur une des
choses qui vont être non contraignantes
non obligatoires pour les entreprises et
qui en réalité et les économistes le
disent finissent par
participer de cette de cette absence
d'augmentation des salaires donc si vous
voulez il va y avoir une orientation
donnée à ces discussions qui je pense ne
sont pas celles désorganisation
syndicales
qui a été signé entre syndicat et de la
valeur est une organisation un accord
qui a été signé par les organisations
syndicales or CGT cela dit ça ne compte
pas du tout
le partage de la valeur a été signé par
des organisations syndicales mais pas du
tout comme réglant le problème bien sûr
si on arrive à faire en sorte que des
entreprises ouvrent la discussion et
donne des primes les organisations
syndicales font leur travail elles
disent ok seulement on va comme
d'habitude se contenter de cela et
qu'est-ce qu'on observe on observe
qu'après les salaires n'augmentent pas
et puis que bah des années où ça va et
bien non non mais des années où ça va
les salariés touchent un petit peu puis
des années où ça va pas elle touche plus
rien du tout et aujourd'hui la situation
elle est elle pour les salariés de très
nombreux et nombreux salariés dans ce
pays qui n'arrivent pas à joindre les
deux bouts qui n'arrivent pas à ils ont
besoin aussi de visibilité quand on a un
loyer à payer tous les mois tout le
monde on a besoin de savoir sur quoi on
peut compter on peut pas compter sur des
primes qui tombent ou ne tombent pas en
fonction de la bonne volonté de
l'employé parce que j'en ai vraiment
important je le rappelle dans cet accord
il n'y a pas d'obligation aucune comme
d'habitude on va écrire
les chantiers qui sont ouverts de la
République avec les partenaires sociaux
il y a la question de l'augmentation des
salaires il y a la question de l'emploi
des seniors de l'usurotravags si il a
parlé l'augmentation des salaires son
premier son voilà
mais bien sûr parce que là il y a une
différence augmentation des revenus pas
des salaires
parce qu'effectivement une prime une
prime une prime peut provoquer une
augmentation des revenus une prime
augmente
il ouvre les chantiers avec les
partenaires sociaux sur l'augmentation
des revenus pour votre ex sur
l'augmentation des revenus augmentation
des salaires sur la question du partage
de la valeur et moi je voudrais juste
noter que la question du partage de la
valeur c'est effectivement une
négociation qui a eu lieu entre les
partenaires sociaux les organisations
syndicales et patronales et que le
gouvernement s'est engagé à transmettre
dans la loi en fait oui à mettre dans la
loi transcrire pour transcrire dans la
retranscrire dans la loi puisque les
partenaires sociaux avaient négocié et
validé pardonnez-moi mais on ne peut pas
dire
vous n'écoutez pas les partenaires
sociaux et quand les partenaires sociaux
font le dialogue social et se mettent
d'accord sur des mesures de partage de
la valeur et que le gouvernement dit on
prendra tel quel que les partenaires
sociaux ont négocié entre eux on nous
dit ah bah non vous n'allez pas assez
loin je pense que le débat il doit avoir
lieu on ira certainement plus loin dans
le cadre des négociations avec les bien
sûr dans le cadre également du débat
parlementaire le débat parlementaire n'a
pas encore eu lieu madame la députée
donc laisser faites confiance
sur la base les partenaires sociaux on
négocie j'essaye de faire en sorte que
tout le monde parle et oui on sent un
peu alors excusez-moi le terme mais
comme un petit piège aussi parce que qui
dit rentrer dans les négociations avec
les syndicats le patronat dit
acceptation finalement de la réforme des
retraites et des 64 ans ça veut dire la
fin de la lutte et on négocie et si vous
n'y êtes pas ça veut dire que toutes les
mesures un peu de justice sociale qui
ont été retoqués par le Conseil
constitutionnel et qui pourrait être
ajoutés par les syndicats et bien les
syndicats ne sont pas à la table donc on
pourrait leur reprocher ça il y a un peu
ce jeu aussi de pression sur les
syndicats qui est menaient là parce pour
faire passer la pilule de la réforme des
retraites et qu'elle soit définitivement
derrière comme ça a été voté enfin
adopté promulguer et puis voilà on passe
il y a cet argument là et puis il y a
aussi le deuxième argument qui est un
peu plus juridique puisque l'article
premier du Code du travail oblige à la
négociation avec les organisations
syndicales et les organisations
patronales dès lors qu'on entre dans un
processus législatif sur une loi qui
touche au travail donc effectivement je
dirais Emmanuel Macron est un peu obligé
de tendre la main aux organisations
syndicales pour aboutir à un projet de
loi qui sera conforme au Code du travail
ça c'est c'est un aspect peut-être
purement juridique mais essentiel le
deuxième aspect à mon sens ce qui manque
dans l'intervention du président de la
République c'est la notion de pouvoir
d'achat alors c'est vrai qu'elle est
liée au travail mais la première
préoccupation des Français aujourd'hui
et la retraite arrive très loin derrière
c'est comment on boucle les fins de mois
et là dessus il a effleuré le sujet mais
je pense qu'il y a pas eu de d'annonces
très concrètes vis-à-vis de la vie
quotidienne des Français c'est ce qu'on
peut
lui reprocher alors je vous propose
d'écouter un autre extrait de de la
locution de d'Emmanuel Macron donc il a
d'abord on l'a rappelé à expliquer
pourquoi cette réforme était nécessaire
ensuite il reconnaît qu'elle n'est pas
acceptée pouvait-il en faire moins non
cette réforme était l'accepter non on
doit en tirer tous les enseignements
personne et surtout pas moi ne peut
rester sourd et ensuite il parle
d'immobilisme et de l'extrémisme écoutez
la réponse
ne peut être ni dans l'immobilisme ni
dans l'extrémisme face à ses colères à
ce sentiment de déclassement d'abandon
nous devons agir ensemble au-delà des
clivages comme j'ai toujours cherché à
le faire au service d'un CAP clair celui
de notre indépendance et de la justice
qui a sans doute quelques
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent à
l'instant et qui n'ont peut-être pas
entendu l'entièreté de l'allocution
d'Emmanuel Macron donc un peu plus de 13
minutes je le disais en ouverture en
titre qu'est-ce qu'on doit en retenir de
cette intervention alors sur les
chantiers donc on va aller très vite 100
jours pour faire un premier bilan sur
trois chantiers principaux c'est ce
qu'il a cité le travail l'ordre et la
justice et puis les progrès pour mieux
vivre en gros les services publics
l'amélioration des services publics
alors si on prend le premier chantier le
travail alors il a beaucoup insisté
d'ailleurs sur les résultats qu'il y
avait été effectués au fur et à mesure
la baisse du chômage 1,7 millions
d'emplois créés depuis six ans et dans
les chantiers c'est la réforme du lycée
professionnel qui a déjà été un petit
peu entamé en tout cas annoncé ramener
aussi les bénéficiaires du RSA au
travail ça aussi c'était dans les clous
même depuis la présidentielle faire en
sorte aussi que le travail paye mieux on
en parlait à l'instant c'est ce nouveau
pacte de la vie au travail qui serait
fait avec les syndicats et le patronat
ceci reviennent à la table des
négociations il a aussi parlé de la
réindustrialisation en tout cas en
termes de résultats en parlant des
usines qui avaient été ouvertes depuis
deux ans 200 usines et puis des emplois
industriels qui sont à nouveau à la
hausse et puis de la planification
écologique qui est en cours et qui doit
déboucher cet été enfin en tout cas
avancer donc ça c'était sur la partie
travail si on passe sur la justice et
l'ordre républicain il s'agit de
continuer à recruter 10 000 gendarmes et
magistrats donc on est sur la justice on
en parlait à l'instant et aussi de
recruter enfin de créer 200 brigades de
gendarmerie dans les campagnes donc là
on est sur les zones rurales et il y a
aussi le contrôle de l'immigration des
illégales et un point important puisque
ça va être annoncé début mai en tout cas
il en a parlé lutter contre la fraude
fiscale et la fraude sociale il y a
aussi tout ce qui concerne les
institutions et la participation
citoyenne notamment la participation
citoyenne ce qui s'est passé sur la fin
de vie là en prenant exemple sur cette
concertation sur le troisième chantier
donc en ce qui concerne les services
publics alors il a parlé de l'éducation
nationale en disant que dès la rentrée
l'école va changer à vue d'oeil il a
parlé des choses qui étaient en cours
rémunération des professeurs notamment
il a insisté là-dessus tout ce qui est
absence aussi des professeurs
accompagnement des élèves pour les maths
donc un gros chantier sur l'école qu'il
veut refonder la santé aussi un système
qui se rebâtit en profondeur on parle
évidemment de ce qui a été fait sur la
fin du numérique clausus de la du reste
à charge des investissements dans
l'hôpital mais il parle aussi des 600
000 patients qui soient en maladie
chronique et qui vont avoir droit à un
médecin traitant ce qui aujourd'hui n'en
trouve pas forcément et avec des
promesses de leur fournir des
engagements aussi des services des
urgences aux hôpitaux et alors un point
pas encore très précis sur les zones
rurales et les loutre-mer des solutions
concrètes pour améliorer la vie
quotidienne
une feuille de route qui sera détaillée
par la première ministre la semaine
prochaine enfin très rapidement merci
beaucoup Emil Ie alors je vous propose
qu'on discute et qu'on débatte autour de
la question des services publics en
écoutant d'abord un cours extrême de la
locution de du président République sur
ce thème
dès la rentrée notre école va changer à
vue d'oeil pour les enseignants qui
seront mieux rémunérés pour les élèves
qui seront davantage accompagnés en
français en mathématiques pour leurs
devoirs et pratiqueront plus de sport à
l'école pour les parents qui verront le
remplacement systématique des
enseignants absents
notre système de santé sera aussi
profondément rebâti d'ici la fin de
cette année 600 000 patients atteints de
maladies chroniques qui n'ont pas de
médecins traitant en disposeront et
d'ici la fin de l'année prochaine nous
devrons avoir
désengorgés tous nos services d'urgence
Sophie taipoliant sur ce thème des
services publics c'est vrai que nous sur
ce plateau dans l'émission sciences
publiques on a malheureusement depuis
six mois un an multiplier les débats
autour de ce qu'on je peux pas dire
autre chose que la grande décrépitude de
nos services publics
il y a certainement une part de
responsabilité d'Emmanuel Macron qui est
au pouvoir depuis six ans il y a
certaines aussi une part de
responsabilité des pouvoirs qui se sont
succédés quel que soit le bord politique
depuis une vingtaine d'années qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de cette exécutif sur
ce thème précis aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous jugez que ce qui est déjà été fait
voilà est un bon point de départ et
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez dans les
prochains mois d'abord pour faire un je
dirais pour inverser la tendance de
manière très très forte il faut des
moyens il faut des moyens on ne peut pas
continuer de gérer nos services publics
en leur demandant sans arrêt de
multiples économies cette année par
exemple quand la loi de programmation de
loi de finances pour la sécurité sociale
a été adoptée elle a été avec une
prévision qui était inférieure à
l'inflation donc on voit bien qu'en
réalité concrètement dans les
établissements hospitaliers il faut
baisser ce qu'on achète puisque on a un
tout petit peu plus mais pas autant que
l'augmentation de l'inflation il faut
des moyens parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans nos services publics
les personnels ont énormément donné
jusqu'à jusque là face à ces politiques
austéritaires qui se sont déployées
depuis de trop nombreuses années ils ont
donné donné donné et là ils sont à un
point de rupture et je vois notamment
les enseignants qui n'acceptent pas
aujourd'hui les propositions qui ont été
de données par le ministre de
l'Éducation ce fameux pacte ou pour
gagner plus il faudrait qu'ils
travaillent plus alors qu'on a déjà des
enseignants qui sont parmi ceux qui
travaillent le plus en Europe parce que
ils sont sur un volume d'heures devant
élève mais tout le travail autour on le
compte pas donc les moyens les moyens
les moyens moi aujourd'hui je me suis
rendu dans un collège on m'a
effectivement dit que il y aurait du
renforcement pour les élèves de 6e en
mathématiques et en français très bien
mais par qui on ne sait pas on est
mi-avril
et on ne sait pas en réalité et vous
savez sur quoi c'est payé
il y a beaucoup de de parents ou de
grands-parents qui nous regardent qui
doivent se sentir concernés et vous
savez ils disent ils ont pour cela
supprimer les heures de cours des
professeurs de technologie comme ça un
jour qui se sont levés le matin quel
mépris encore on leur a dit bah vous
n'enseignerez plus aux enfants de 6e
parce que ça va permettre de payer
d'autres professeurs qui vont venir
faire du renfort en maths et en français
et pour vous devez nos services publics
et j'en terminerai par là outre des
moyens il faut du respect pour les
personnels du respect pour les
personnels qui ont tant donné ces
dernières années et évidemment tout
particulièrement pendant la crise
sanitaire le respect mais c'est pas de
ça on sait pas du respect dont on a
beaucoup eu qu'on a beaucoup reçu de la
part du président de la République ce
soir je trouve
et c'est aussi une des choses qui manque
cruellement le service public Xavier
yakovie sur cette question de des moyens
comment effectivement on pourrait parler
de la loi programmation militaire aussi
des de l'argent qui est mis sur la table
et moi je pense je suis pas là pour
donner mon avis mais qu'on en a besoin
mais comment concilier ces engagements
ces enjeux pour nos services publics et
la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte mais je
pense et cela objectivement même si
l'opposition
s'oppose c'est normal objectivement le
budget de l'Éducation nationale le
budget de la santé et des hôpitaux le
budget de la Défense le budget du
ministère de l'Intérieur la justice et
de la justice ce sont que des budgets
qui ont augmenté ces six dernières
années rien que sur la justice nous
sommes à 33% d'augmentation 15 milliards
que nous venons de voter pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur
l'éducation nationale est devenue le
premier budget désormais de l'État avant
de vous interrompre la situation elle
est toujours aussi critique dans dans la
plupart de ces services publics où
est-ce qu'on investit plus parce
qu'effectivement la situation est
catastrophique dans un certain nombre de
nos services publics et parce que nous
rattrapons aussi souvent des années et
des décennies de sous-investissement
dans nos services publics la question de
l'hôpital ça ne date pas de six ans ça
ne date même pas 10 ans ça date de
beaucoup plus parce qu'on a sous investi
pendant des années et on a pressurisé le
service public hospitalier et donc oui
effectivement depuis la covid qui a mis
en lumière ce dysfonctionnement et c'est
ce manque d'investissement dans
l'hôpital nous avons mis 19 milliards
sur l'investissement nous n'avons
revalorisé le les métiers du des métiers
des soignants et donc nous avons besoin
effectivement de continuer sur cette sur
cet axe là il y a un travail aussi qui
est fait par Agnès Firmin le Baudot
notre Ministre délégué en charge du
personnel soignant de justement
travailler sur une meilleure
organisation territoriale pour pour le
médecin les déserts médicaux on parlait
tout à l'heure des 600 000 patients qui
sont en maladie chronique qui n'arrivent
pas à avoir de médecin traitant ça c'est
aussi un engagement et la ministre est
sur sur ces sujets au quotidien après il
y a la question de l'éducation et de
l'enfance le service la création du
service public de la petite enfance qui
a été annoncé par Jean-Christophe comble
le ministre des Solidarités c'est aussi
une réponse assez besoin de mode de
garde à ses besoins d'accompagnement des
enfants au plus au plus jeune âge pour
permettre justement au plus modeste de
pouvoir avoir cet accompagnement de
l'institution des le plus jeune âge le
fait de faire en sorte que le
l'obligation de scolarisation à partir
de trois ans c'est aussi pour permettre
de lutter contre une inégalités des
destins qui étaient aussi dans la
promesse présidentielle depuis 2017 tout
ça ce sont des éléments importants la
revalorisation des enseignants à partir
de septembre c'est aussi un point pour à
la fois le respect pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui forment notre jeunesse mais
aussi d'un point de vue de pour investir
dans l'éducation nationale quelques
réactions de personnalités politiques à
la suite de cette allocution du
Président de la République
alors c'est un patchwork je vais dans un
peu tous les sens je pars de Marine Le
Pen qui parle d'une pratique déconnectée
solitaire et obtuses du pouvoir Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui c'est un style un peu
télégraphique irréel Macron point
complètement hors de la réalité point il
assume le vol de deux ans de liberté
Fabien Roussel ceux qui n'ont pas écouté
n'ont rien perdu et Éric Ciotti un
catalogue de vœux pieux sans remise en
cause est-ce que vous êtes aussi
critique
il y a pas eu de remise en cause très
peu c'est ce qu'on peut ça a été balayé
très vite au départ il fallait lire
entre les on va juste répondre sur les
services publics si vous me permettez
parce que effectivement les moyens ont
été réinjectés il faut repenser
l'organisation des services publics les
territorialisés davantage parce que
derrière il y a deux écueils le
sentiment que les français
payent de plus en plus d'impôts de
consentement l'impôt sans avoir la
qualité de service public en corrélation
et puis après il y a le problème de la
dette nous empruntions en 2021 0% nous
sommes à 3%, les projections sur 2027
c'est 70 milliards de services de la
dette ce qu'on appelle les intérêts de
la dette qui vont peser sur le budget
risque le premier poste le premier poste
et c'est 70 milliards on aurait on en
aurait bien besoin justement
en territorialisant davantage en
réorganisant davantage au plus proche du
terrain parce que effectivement des
moyens doivent être mis supplémentaires
que ça soit dans au niveau du ministère
là de l'Intérieur au niveau de la loi
l'openi ça a été une bonne loi elle a
été votée d'ailleurs quasi à l'unanimité
au niveau du Sénat on entend on attend
la même chose dans le domaine de la
santé dans le domaine du éducation dans
le domaine de la justice après il faut
que l'État se reconcentre effectivement
sur le régalien parce qu'on réinvestit
dans l'éducation dans dans la santé dans
le dans la justice c'est le principe de
subsidiarité qui doit qui doit faire
faire preuve c'est-à-dire redescendre au
plus proche du terrain pour éviter
l'acte de décentralisation certainement
alors un modélise à Pasquier je vous
donne la parole jusqu'à présent parce
qu'on a eu un Emmanuel Macron très
pressé pour les 100 jours moi je prends
juste l'exemple pour les services
publics des services d'urgence puisque
là il dit on va régler on va désengorger
2024 oui mais vous vous rendez compte en
termes d'agenda quand même la covid ça a
commencé en 2020 en 2020 on s'est rendu
compte que c'était compliqué alors que
c'était déjà le cas avant puisque les
soignants mentionnés manifester déjà
pour dire que c'était déjà avant 2020 on
arrive en 2020 on nous dit ah oui mais
former les médecins c'est compliqué
c'est long et on arrive en 2023 en
disant on est toujours sur ce contenu de
la santé entre-temps mais il a peut-être
pas été suffisant
par rapport au vœu je dirais pas pieux
mais on veut d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir
et à cette envie d'aller très vite et
ben il y a des choses qui sont pas les
très vite déjà et ça serait bien qu'on
s'en occupe et puis sur le et sur les
services publics on a l'impression que
plus on réorganise plus ça souffre au
niveau du rural au niveau des campagnes
et moins ils ont le service public
se questionner sur la méthode de
réorganisation oui c'est pour ça qu'on
parle de territorialisation Sophie en
écoutant Stéphane Audier tout à l'heure
je vous voyais dire ça fait 20 ans qu'on
dit la même chose
on réorganise à tout va sans arrêt dans
l'unique but d'ailleurs de baisser les
budgets et on voit le résultat faut
arrêter avec ça c'est pas une question
si on a aujourd'hui des problèmes dans
nos services publics c'est pas tant une
question d'organisation
que une question de moyen quand vous
avez dans des écoles des enfants
situation de handicap ou les personnels
qui sont censés s'en occuper sont
tellement mal payés tellement
déconsidérés etc vous n'arrivez pas à
recruter vous savez c'est une question
de moyens c'est pas une question
d'organisation c'est une question de
formation c'est une question de salaire
c'est une question de statut donc c'est
une question de moyens donc après moi ce
que j'entends et je reconnais bien là
effectivement la ligne politique des
républicains et de Bruno Le Maire c'est
que cette qui n'est plus républicain
mais qui partagent mais qui partagent
qui partagent ce point de vue et
finalement effectivement le nid droite
ni gauche le en même temps a fait long
feu oui c'est ça c'est surtout et droite
et bien c'est c'est ce que j'observe moi
ce que je dis dans la presse c'est que
le budget 2024
s'annonce très serré et que on demande
dans les ministères de faire encore et
encore des propositions d'économie c'est
ce que je lis dans la presse publique
mais enfin d'un autre côté on est en
train de proposer de préparer un budget
de rigueur je reprends la main pour vous
partager une des réactions attendues ce
soir celle de Laurent Berger le
secrétaire national de la CFDT il parle
d'un vide dans l'intervention du
président de la République il y a un
espèce de vide dans la intervention du
président de la République il y a rien
dedans qui est une forme de
considération à tous ces travailleurs et
travailleuses qui sont touchés parce
qu'ils vont devoir travailler deux
années de plus donc on attendait autre
chose évidemment et quant aux
perspectives qui sont données c'est un
peu un discours de la méthode pour une
dixième fois mais rien de concret
Xavier yakovelli il y a du chemin encore
avant d'avoir tout ce tout ce monde
autour d'une table pour pour négocier
les trois mois à écoulé on laissait des
traces quoi et des blessures ça laissait
des traces comme la dit le président ce
n'est pas une réforme qui a été acceptée
elle était nécessaire mais elle n'a pas
été accepté et donc effectivement il
faut dans son attitude à lui vis-à-vis
des leaders syndicaux et notamment de
Laurent Berger c'est peut-être un mea
culpa c'est pour ça qu'il faut il l'a
dit continuer à libérer les énergies
continuer à protéger les plus faibles et
continuer à unir réunir le pays et donc
ça passe aussi par un dialogue social
qui soit renoué avec les partenaires
sociaux je pense que c'est important on
a un certain nombre de grands projets à
mener et ça se fera de toute façon dans
la concertation et ça se fera dans la
concentration et dedans il y a personne
autour de la table au bout d'un moment
on ne peut pas seulement être dans la
critique il faut aussi être dans
l'action et en l'occurrence la porte est
ouverte le président de la République la
réaffirmé à la fois pour les partis
politiques pour tous les partis
politiques qui souhaitent aujourd'hui
partager dans ce travail pour au service
des Français et bien sûr avec les
partenaires sociaux et les représentants
à l'être humain Stéphane Olivier je vais
couper la parole tout à l'heure donc je
vous la rends et juste après Sophie je
voudrais me positionner par rapport à
leur berger il a une problématique c'est
quel premier mai en ligne de mire il a
réclamé un délai de l'attente entre
l'acceptation enfin la promulgation de
la loi et le retour au niveau au niveau
de la table des négociations je pense
que dans 15 jours 3 semaines le temps
sera à l'apaisement pour qu'il peut pas
faire il peut pas dire autre chose ce
soir il aura peut-être un autre discours
dans 15 jours c'est ce que vous il aura
sans doute un discours un peu plus
apaisé je pense que il y a eu une main
tendue quand même du président de la
République ce soir il faut être très
clair peut-être qu'il annoncera ou
Elizabeth borne annoncera d'autres
d'autres mesures en faveur des syndicats
notamment une conférence sociale parce
que je pense que c'est essentiel d'avoir
un dialogue qui soit permanent
un peu le nouveau pack de la vie au
travail c'est pas encore une conférence
sociale encore une grande conférence
peut-être effectivement je repose la
question puis après
autour de la stratégie dans Laurent
Berger c'est vrai que il est la CFDT
estampillé syndicat réformiste il y a
bien un moment où il va falloir qu'il
revienne autour de la table écoutez en
fait le problème c'est pas tant de
revenir autour de la table ou pas ça
certainement vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est la confiance et depuis des années
les organisations syndicales ont perdu
toute confiance et singulièrement
d'ailleurs je crois de manière assez
personnelle entre Emmanuel Macron et
Laurent Berger quand on voit par exemple
ces derniers mois sur la réforme de la
location chômage on a mis je veux dire
les syndicats complètement hors du jeu
là la réforme de la retraite donc faut
toujours venir discuter ce sera ce sera
aux organisations syndicales de
déterminer si elle souhaite participer
ou non au rendez-vous qui leur seront
proposés mais la confiance c'est
certainement pas avec ce type
d'allocution qu'on l'a rétabli Xavier
sur l'attitude quand même d'Emmanuel
Macron je rejoins un peu ce que nous dit
Sophie taillipoliant parce que il a
d'abord un peu gommé les corps
intermédiaires ils l'a presque même
théorisé avant son élection et dans les
premiers mois de son premier mandat et
on a l'impression que finalement il
tombe dans son propre piège aujourd'hui
parce que là sans les syndicats
qu'est-ce qu'il va pouvoir faire dans
les grandes réformes dont ils nous
parlent il a besoin des syndicats autour
de la table je pense qu'effectivement
dans les premières les premiers mois de
son premier quinquennat effectivement il
y avait une volonté d'aller vite et
d'avoir cette fougue on va dire de d'un
jeune président qui a été élu pour
réformer et c'était la volonté
réformatrice du président il aimerait
bien retrouver là avec les 100 jours
qu'il a effectivement apporté qui a été
amené une large majorité pardon aux
précédents avec quinquennat je pense que
il y a aussi l'exercice du pouvoir qui
fait que on est dans un pays un vieux
pays un pays qui est pas facile à
réformer mais qui a envie de réforme
malgré tout et donc avec un certain
nombre de corps intermédiaire qu'il faut
prendre en considération et qu'il faut
associer pour pouvoir bien réformer
parce que c'est pas le tout de réformer
il faut bien réformer et que ça soit il
y ait du consentement aussi sur sur les
réformes et je crois que ça c'est la
volonté du président maintenant allez un
mode conclusion Stéphane Olivier ce que
vous avez dit changement de méthode
enfin nulle a tellement promis la fin de
méthode que bon maintenant passer des
mots aux actes on a eu plusieurs
séquences avec de grands discours de
grandes déclarations suivies de peu
d'actes en fait et c'est c'est là dessus
après la grande interrogation c'est
comment réussir en 100 jours ce qu'on
n'a pas réussi en six ans on peut se
poser légitimement la question et il
faudra réinventer en fait et la relation
avec les Français qui est rompu à
l'heure actuelle et ça ça prendra du
temps c'est pas sur une allocution qu'on
qu'on change de donne d'où l'apaisement
qui souhaitait par le Président de la
République oui mais c'est sur le long
terme merci
tout petit mot de conclusion mais rapide
alors effectivement il y a un côté
extrêmement paradoxal voir
schizophrénique entre apaisement d'un
côté et urgence de 100 jours de l'autre
ce qu'on voit c'est que il faut
manifester le 1er mai pour continuer à
mettre un rapport de force vis-à-vis
d'Emmanuel Macron parce que visiblement
il ne peut comprendre que cela puisque
l'écoute n'est pas son force on avance
vite et à plusieurs on avance beaucoup
plus loin
ça ça fait du bien merci beaucoup merci
à tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
premier